governor newsome
his uh ex-wife jennifer newsom
jennifer siebold newsom i think that is
her name yes she called me and she set
up a meeting with me to meet her someone
in brentwood and i actually went and i
got very like creeped out and i saw her
sitting where her sister meet her and i
looked at her and i i turned around and
went back into my car and drove away she
wanted to meet me she was when is this
when is this just this is about uh six
months before the new york times article
in weinstein that i set up broke
okay and she called me on behalf of a
theranost board member
the
lawyer for
longtime lawyer of hillary bill and
clinton and weinstein
won david boyce
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
new york times best-selling author a
global activist and a destroyer of bad
people rose mcgowan finally welcome to
the reuben report finally dave rubin and
so we meet
hello destroyer destroyer of bad people
i felt that sort of
captured your essence how do you feel
about that i think that's right on
target there was somebody right after um
because i started going after governor
cuomo about last january right away on
behalf of lindsey boylan
and someone on twitter what the day he
resigned he
wrote someone wrote on twitter a woman
god help you if rose mcgowan comes after
you and i'm like finally someone
recognizes me christ how many times i
have to tell these people like i mean
what i say
you have seriously destroyed some people
some pretty awful people and we'll get
to some of that stuff and you know i
want to talk about some new stuff with
you too but i've just learned something
about you in the last couple days that
we've been chatting that uh you're a
larry elder gal
and i'm a larry elder guy
here we are
talk to me yeah i was that weird uh i
don't know if i might have been the only
performer in california ever under
contract to paramount studios or viacom
that would leave set and listen to am
640 larry elder after that would be john
and ken sometimes if i got really riled
up i would pull over on the way home
i always use the name tracy i try to
find the most basic name i could find
because my voice was somewhat
recognizable so i was like rose
obviously that's and i want i would
literally call and go off on the the
teachers union of california or la or
like the vice you know the why is the
state legislature one full calendar year
because it used to only be six months
for the state legislature that they got
paid and then they're like well we can
achieve more if you pay us for a whole
year but yeah you only work for six
months if
so yeah so you you you actually use the
fake name and were calling into larry
elder show over the years yes
and were you i mean i don't consider you
conservative and i know the labels all
sort of mean nothing and especially for
someone like you the idea of putting you
in a box is kind of nuts but like do you
so i mean do you sort of consider
yourself conservative now or
libertarianish or no like what
smart intelligent
like not dumb and logical
unless
nobody seems to like to listen to that
labels to me i mean if you flip things
all the time like the other night
someone is yelling at me and like i'm
trying to sleep and i was like
congratulations i am trying to stay
awake
or you know you just i like flipping the
language so like what literally the
etymology of language is something that
fascinates me so if we took conservative
and if you take the word liberal both
now have like a because they've been
slimed and smeared in and weaponized
right aggressively weaponized against
each other and against humans all over
the world but if you look at the
definition of both they're quite
beautiful
and both are valid and both can co-exist
so like
you know
libservative i don't know i don't know
that's not pretty i'll come up with
something better but i really think just
by taking the power out of what
something traditionally means i mean it
was all invented at one point anyway
well you know that jordan peterson guy
that i toured with was always talking
about that healthy tension between
conservative and liberal that that's
what you want if in a if you're going to
be in a sane society i don't know about
a sane society because i think that's
still very
limited i think like there's only two
options at that point if you have only
two options ever and there's no other
choice i mean i think the biggest thing
that you know i would like to run on if
i ever run for anything if they can make
it so i don't have to live in the us but
can be a political figure there i'll do
it
but yeah you're not thrilled with the us
these days huh
i guess that throws 11. we'll put a pin
in that we'll go back to it
but you know the thing is like um the
largest voting block i'm pretty sure is
the non-voter
who's representing them
maybe me
rose mcgowan non-voters from another
country
yeah i have a podcast i'm doing um i've
recorded four episodes so far definitely
not normal i guess according to podcast
standards the the first one the
engineers like okay begin and i'm like
[ __ ] what now
and i smoke a bowl in the uh i take a
toke into the microphone exhale and then
just free form and
who knows what comes out but it weirdly
works i think so one of the episodes is
about
um
the fact that
we are constantly talking about the
voters in the media in the us especially
and all over but the people that are not
the voters so why aren't we talking to
them why aren't we analyzing that we
know why because they're only given two
choices and it's it's clearly not
working and as many alcoholics who go to
a a no the definition of insanity is uh
doing the same thing and expecting
different results
yeah we're quite good at that in the
united states uh let's back up though
for a second to this elder situation
because i'm i'm pretty amazed that you
were calling in like i can just sort of
picture you on mulholland
like they got to go into the archives
and find some of these things but it's
not just that that you like larry and
you like what's going on with his
campaign and we got a couple days left
to save this freaking state uh you
really do not like gavin newsom right
no i do not like gavin newsom i do not
take it away same at all in fact i think
um
i would submit that single parents in
california get less money for food from
the government than he spends on his
daily moisturizing treatments
and i i think that goes you know that
sounds like a little zinger but no it
really goes to show what these people
prioritize okay who they really are
i was in california when he was
lieutenant governor i've been there you
know i was living there for a long time
when he was like desperately trying to
be governor and it's like dude you look
like guido junior from a movie what are
you doing like you're not the man and
you're alive well he looks like the guy
from american psycho well i think he's
he's the guy he's christian bale in
american psycho fairly sure that he did
some like a deep fake ai where he stuck
his face on christian bales in the
shower scene and probably also
masturbates to that on the loop just
saying
can you say that on your show
you can say that on my show we have no
rules here
so it's not so much that i love larry
elder because some things we i you know
know like there's you know certain
things that i'm not as conservative on
or i don't even like that word like i
said but or square square okay square
i'm a little bit more like i like
weirdos i like tiny adventures i like
seeing where the night goes hey
but i also like his mind i like his
dedication i love his passion i love the
fact that he is a true patriot what we
need is patriots what we need are
patriots i am a patriot you are a
patriot anybody can be a patriot the
non-voter can be a patriot gavin newsom
not a patriot
there now you see when i flash anger
people always think i'm like that all
the time it's like a thunder cloud and
then i'm back to me what i had to do
right
yeah and that was that was hopeful not
anger thank you that's what i think
people always say angry and i'm like
passionate and like and and i feel like
i'm like
like the cheerleader like come on we can
do this people we've got this
rise up you know what's been happening
to you you know what the truth is stop
suspecting it and go into the fact that
it is a fact okay let's operate from a
point of fact at this point not that i
get so many people most especially
american media likes to do this to me um
so you feel this way
no i didn't tell you i felt about it i
told you today this guy was blue in los
angeles i did not tell you wow i feel
really great or horrible that this guy
was blue this guy's blue so it's like
gaslighting and they do it individually
and cult members cult structural
societies what they mistake is that they
you know in the movies and and i grew up
in one i would know i have like a phd in
that
but how i diagnose it
in the us i'll take that as my test
model
is that you know where they always get
it wrong in films literature this and
that is that it's portrayed as like this
fingali where everyone's just kind of
nodding and then goes about in their
drone-like way it's not quite like that
there is the you know the authoritarian
but then it's up to every single member
of every single micro or macro to cross
hypnotize at all times and if one person
say me say you say larry elder say the
punk weirdo that's like yelling truth
from under a bridge whoever you listen
to stands up and is like no
we're not having this
you know what is true and you you just
say it and you take it on the chin for
saying it i've certainly taken it on the
chin like in every other part of my body
like
don't say i'm like but you all know it
and i what what my enemies and your
enemies i'm guessing fundamentally don't
understand
are my motivations maybe yours i have
no skin in this game other than the fact
that i can other than the fact that i
worked my ass off to stay just relevant
enough worldwide as an actress
so i could life hack their system so i
could gain access to their cameras and
microphones and i could [ __ ] them in the
ass in the lubrication here i am nice to
meet you dave
and now you know
but rose on twitter it often says some
people say or experts say doesn't that
mean we're supposed to always follow
that information that would be bob in
the coffee room so some people some
people could be you know my uh imaginary
friend like some people gets you away
with a lot of stuff some people is also
like so you feel this way huh well they
look at you
like the only way we're gonna grow and
get better is if like call it what it is
you know just just it's like i've done
it and the world has tried to kill me
yes i almost said c because i live in
america but um you know it is really i
think incumbent on all of us uh to to
just shake we don't have time for
running out of time so like on that
interview on nightline the last thing
she said and it was like a warning in
this journalist's eye she leans into me
these are very powerful people you're
talking about
and i look at her and i pause
don't underestimate the effect of a good
pause dave
and i say i know
so am i
and i took that from an army slogan
weirdly that i started thinking about do
you remember back in the day when they
changed it from uh be all you can be
which is you know a great tagline a
great slogan army be all you can be and
then they changed it to an army of one i
was like
hey that doesn't not quite as catchy
right man but then i started breaking it
down and i was like i started thinking
about it that's about eight years before
i set up the articles to expose
weinstein
and i started thinking about it i'm like
an army of one well i can be an army and
i can say i'm an army so i started just
hashtagging rose army i had no army but
i do like the spartans and i really like
their trojan horse idea
so then i had to sound like i was coming
with all sorts of backup
um but it was you know and of course i
was portrayed as she's coming after men
and i'm like
believe me there's so many women that
support this structure that you know
like let's take uh the new governor
everyone's like the first female
governor of new york
uh
she was there so she knew stuff too
you know so it's a cult takes everybody
to support it it takes a cross hypnosis
and it takes the gaslighting but the
thing is like what's great about you
your viewers your
people that think differently that look
at it just take your lenses and go a
little bit abstract a little bit above
and look down
and and dissect the situation and your
truth even if it's just you that knows
it that is enough that is enough for you
to be an army of one and an army of one
can then tagline with other armies other
armies and we can become a massive force
and i think that's beautiful
so that being said as someone that has
you know had the machine try to destroy
them over and over again and who took
down
the most powerful people in hollywood i
mean weinstein specifically what do you
think it is about you like you
specifically that like
allows you to do it and keep going
because everyone that i talk to wherever
i go they're always like oh i want to
speak up more but i have a job or oh i
want to speak more but i have kids or
all of the things that are legit reasons
right they're legit at some level and
then on the other hand
you know they know they have something
inside them that they're holding back
that's feeding it i mean that's the sort
of hypnosis that you're talking about
the big difference honestly is that i
was not raised like you or pretty much
anybody else on this planet and at first
people get like take a little like
umbrage at that i'm unique too yes you
are yes you are yes you are absolutely
but if you look at me like kind of a
feral child that was born and raised in
the woods with no real contact with the
outside world except for very select
people that raised all the children to
be super minds what would happen to
these children if they didn't know the
outside world if we did not use their
language if we did not expose them to
really drilling home they were a boy or
a girl or a race or anything they were
just
minds
that's me and then overnight you know
got broken up the organization the group
i was in that my father was the leader
of and i got thrown out into gig harbor
washington and to a
really unattractive military-based
school
boom boom
and in my language in my birth language
english is my third language
and my first um which very few people
other than people the children of god
know and speak or spoke um
everybody that was not us were called
systemize
wait what what is the language
it's invented but so is yours
no but what's it called
it doesn't have any i don't i don't know
the name it was just what we spoke and
so our word for everybody outside our
walls
uh we called everybody systemites
and they're not wrong that's the thing
the problem with most cults and why they
don't succeed and why an american cult
as a total cult cannot succeed or any
nation cult cannot succeed both micro
and macro
is because they're formed
i think in a way that
really negatively impacts the reason
those people you're talking about why
they can't get there
i'm not just kids or jobs and yes you
have to be pretty much selfless and
willing to take the hits i i
but also
i was not
notified at age three or four that i was
a girl and here's what you can't do
we're gonna tie your heinz
we're gonna tie your hands behind your
back with politeness little girl and
we're gonna train you since round age
two three go sit on your uncle's lap
give him a kiss you don't want to give
him a kiss
think about it
then the boys you get put in straight
jackets
around two three
have fun getting out of that for the
rest of your life so your life the
systemites everybody that was not us
essentially and the reason why we didn't
succeed the cult i was in that my father
led did not succeed is because he came
from the systemite world
i did not so for me
i have no i have no skin in this game
and all the skin i'm going for broke
because i can because why not and i was
a weird kid sure uh i had like venn
diagrams of like napoleon's battle plans
on my wall with pins alexander the great
but then i'd read like one i'd read like
his writings like napoleon or something
then i'd read like five biographies on
that like that particular battle and i
would just like figure it out what the
truth was for me i was always trying to
find the truth and what um but i just
like strategy and and
one of the great ways that i succeed i
made no money from my success in terms
of you know slaying
the giant hydra that is the hellscape
we're living in i'm like stay down
you know i need backup like animals um
but i i i slay dragons why
what else am i doing
at the end of my uh podcast which is
called uh the cultural reset it's gonna
be on substance i end it with why why
the [ __ ] not
and you know what sometimes it's fun you
have fun right sometimes we have fun
yeah and people like when i called oprah
lizard you know which i believe is true
um i've always felt that way when i saw
her first on tv when i was small when i
came to the states i'd never seen a
television i didn't know who she was but
i saw her interviewing somebody that was
in an immense amount of pain
and her eyes were like not connected at
all but the words coming out of her
mouth were very soft and soothing
but nothing in the eyes connected and i
was i was like i actually was sorry my
ear thing is having a situation
it's i was scared of her that i wasn't
scared of her but i was like
like my ah like i just i've had and
maybe it is because growing up with a
father who was
very good at wiring people's minds he
was very good at it
not always for nefarious reasons but
always for ego reasons i don't have that
ego i just don't um i might um seem
egotistical to some i've certainly been
called that but i think it's also people
are unusual unused to people saying what
they're good at just plainly i also know
what i'm really bad at i suck at quite a
few things i'm also [ __ ] great at a
lot of things so
go from there
so there we are
um
before we completely lose the uh the
political part yeah the new the newsome
party so
yeah no it all sort of fits but i know
you you've got something you wanted to
talk about about newsome specifically
yes dave thank you for reminding me
oh i feel like hal 2000
yes dave
no dave sorry dave no dave sorry dave
that's strange so yes governor newsom
his uh ex-wife jennifer newsom
jennifer siebold knews him i think that
is her name yes she called me and she
set up a meeting with me to meet her
someone in brentwood and i actually went
and i got very like creeped out and i
saw her sitting where her sister meet
her and i looked at her and i i turned
around and went back into my car and
drove away she wanted to meet me she was
when is this when is this just this is
about uh six months before the new york
times article in weinstein that i set up
broke
okay and she called me on behalf of a
therapist board member the
lawyer for
long time lawyer of hillary and bill and
clinton and weinstein
won david boyce so this woman i don't
know some blonde lady named with the
last name of newsome cold calls me i can
say
david boyce wants to know what it would
take
to make you happy
six months before the weinstein story
what do we take to make you happy which
you took as for those that might be
playing along a little bit slowly
i i don't know but i don't know if it
would be fiscal remuneration i don't
know i like absolutely nothing would
make me happy you falling off the planet
david boyce and your whole company if
you all fall off the planet i would be
happy since you cannot do that
i will remain unhappy with you and you
shall deal with my displeasure
but they're scary these are operators
they're tied into sdk knickerbocker
they're tied into hillary they're tied
into nancy pelosi this is all backdoor
[ __ ] for their gain and we're tired
of it we're suffering people are dying
not just the stupid ass cold but because
their [ __ ] system is [ __ ] killing
us i've had it and i think a lot of us
had so now it's time to go from feeling
i feel this is all [ __ ] to fact it
is all [ __ ] and vote larry elder
cause why why the [ __ ] not what have you
got to lose how's it going people how's
your systemite society working for you
try something different might as well
there's my pitch
like a pro like a best campaign like you
know i just like for me like i used to
volunteer years ago at a place called
covenant house and i never did it with
cameras and i would go and i would speak
to homeless runaway uh trans kids which
you know um because i was taken in by
them when i was a homeless 13 year old
that's who raised me they were like my
mother's right so i always felt like i
would repay the favor and i knew that
state-run therapy could not help them in
the way that i could because i don't use
language the same way most people do and
i'm not scared so when a kid when the
the therapist would say this goes
together with this how did that make you
feel
and they're like
they're like [ __ ] the hard shell comes
up that doesn't make me feel anything
and and i because i'm not bound by state
laws or regular normal ways conversing
which is why i'm effective i believe
is is is simply because i said
really
that would hurt me so badly
i would feel so betrayed and abandoned
if the person i came here with abandoned
me on the first day and left me to rot
on the streets
that would like
shake my faith humans and everything
else and i feel like that is what the
state of california needs to say to
gavin newsom on election day you have
betrayed us you have hurt us you and
your whole type because you are one in a
long line of lizards and we don't want
you anymore i like lizards i like real
lizards but i don't like the fake
lizards
so clean house you can do it go to the
polls do it for me because i'm not gonna
he got this
just to be totally clear here gavin
newsom's
wife
or ex wanted to sit or wanted to sit
down with you which then turned out to
be on the phone where she said
what
can harvey weinstein's lawyer do
to make this story go away gavin what's
the connection to gavin newsom's wife
why why was it that she was the one that
was calling you
mystified me too because they tried
every way they could
they tried every single way they could
to get to me i mean my literary agency
duprey miller who i hired to represent
me to shepherd and protect my book from
weinstein
jan miller um
it's a big literary firm and they were
secretly exposed they were exposed for
secretly working with weinstein the
entire time they're supposed to be
protecting my book
they were exposed to the new york times
for that and when i met her this jan
miller woman she was bragging about like
giving a 15 000 plate dinner for david
boyce and bill and hillary that night in
dallas so you know do the math it's all
connected it is all connected one at a
time i am coming
yeah i mean that seems like a fairly big
scandal with an election coming in four
days basically
i guess in my world it's like tuesday at
2 p.m it's just like another in my heart
like literally the governor's wife
calling me to you know basically shut me
up with money about the biggest sex
scandal of all time
it's a serial rapist and i load the
media they're always like disgraced
producer i'm like if he was an indigent
black rapist would you say disgraced
disgraced homeless rapist no he is a
convicted
serial rapist
let's just say it we can all be adults
it wasn't pleasant it wasn't fun they
really built a beast in me and all i
ever wanted to do in my whole life dave
was lay under a tree at night in the
grass and look for owls
i know i know i know that's true with
you you love the owls and we've got this
very bizarre owl connection we both have
owls hanging outside our houses not in
part two but so i said the things if
there are people out there that can go
in on this and and work it out and
expose more yes they're all part of it
and this whole like oprah saying like or
meryl streep or uh gavin newsom oh we
were in our ivory tower we just didn't
know anything about it we're too fancy
for that that's just those you know the
little actresses they were short skirts
they deserved it no
this was a machine this is a machine it
has many many tentacles one tentacle is
the human trafficking arm of it right he
had a daily appointment for rape 1pm
around 1 p.m every day daily appointment
for many years anywhere there's a film
festival and it takes his protection i
introduced hillary at aussie fest about
three something years ago in central
park so it's like it was like a rock
concert for speakers so they got me up
there and at this point i just really
found out how deep involved in in this
whole thing like that camp was right um
and that it hadn't really been publicly
outed yet by me or anybody
and so they said okay so you're gonna
introduce hillary and i'm like great
i got this
so the last thing i said to this like it
was like a rock concert right i'm up
there
and i said and the last thing i will say
to you all today
harvey weinstein was protected by the
democratic party welcome to the stage
hillary clinton
and this collective
northern liberal gasp
like and suddenly i was literally like
yanked off stage they wouldn't let me go
back to my purse i'm walking out of
central park i see her like town car go
by see the hair like you know in profile
and i just see your face like in profile
go
and i was like nailed it
wow but i can i serve i serve why
because i was born to
is there video of that i mean that
that's it's got to be somewhere um maybe
let's say i looked for it on their site
but of course now you know they take
down everything
but it like somebody out there has that
video i would certainly i certainly did
it
so so what do you think this thing is
sort of is it like a hollywood
protection not even just hollywood is it
just the machine protection racket it's
sort of we're all sort of in it whatever
it is we're all protecting each other
every now and again we have to sacrifice
somebody
so that the masses don't fully get what
we're all doing because you know when
you're mentioning oprah and meryl streep
and everything i know a lot of people
are going to be like but i like oprah i
like you
i would like to like them too i'm a i'm
trust me every time i discover someone
is exactly as i suspected i am very like
bummed out it doesn't make me happy
does not make me happy gosh if you don't
think i want someone to be real like
please somebody be real just somebody be
what they say but the reality is i meet
bus drivers that are real the reality is
i meet an owner of a 7-11 franchise in
detroit named robert he's real those are
the real people right not them and you
know and i know that the pentagon
like cia it all goes like i believe the
reason we're not at war with iran right
now and people might start laughing is
because top gun 2 was delayed because of
covet now you think about that for a
second top gun won no you're going to
look i just i while i was off the grid i
only watched one movie basically it was
top gun so i'm going to really follow
this with you right so if you look at it
historically so after the vietnam war
very low military
enrollment people saw it for what it was
they were not into it they're like done
so then they're like damn we need a war
soon we know ramp it up so what do we do
top gun so anytime you mention the cia
even in like a sitcom you have to say
something positive about them they
control and approve any use of even
those three letters right any use of
anything like the pentagon any anything
like that so it's tip for chat but it's
also total directives
and the directive is we need to staff
our restaurant that's opening in six
months to a year that's the directive
it worked top gun came out my little
brother watched it he went to the air
force academy he's a fighter pilot he
flies f-16s and f-18s you know the
realest text i ever got in my life was
from him when he was in afghanistan
texting me i just dropped on my first
target and now they all ask why did i do
that
because
these people all work in concert on the
on on the surface they say that
america's number one export is uh
hollywood
first of all they're stupid
they're not good with business they
could be making so much more because
they have a terrible work ethic and
their dodos they leave a lot of money on
the table but more importantly and
they're making a lot of crappy [ __ ] too
at this point um
like they're not even faking it anymore
right well just like everyone's like oh
god they're going to kill epstein and
then they do and they're like yep i
guess they did
like they're not even pretending right
exactly but like
every part of it it's like when mexico
try to get its land back from being
stolen by the us
who runs to hollywood with the a new and
invented word called marijuana let's
make his own latin spanish scary mexican
and then they do one-minute movies in
hollywood they pump out it's like 1940s
before all the other movies
a jewish guy painted brown in a sombrero
like chasing after a white college girl
smoking the meadow like that like this
is how they do it and it is in concert
and it is brainwashing and it is
manipulation
and it's all connected the reason
there's if if hollywood was in fact
america's number one export
do you think there would be government
oversight there is none
there's no human resources department
for that
[ __ ] and if it stayed local if it
stayed there that would be great i
wouldn't [ __ ] with them and be like
losers hang out but their lucrative goes
to the world
and i know that people are putting
thought in your head which is why four
days after
the weinstein expose broke i tweeted at
jeff bezos one two three four and i made
my case
by
two hours later his
personal attorney called me on my cell
phone probably got my number off my
amazon account maybe i don't know
and uh and i explained what was up
ice roy price head of the studio why
i was deeply offended that that stupid
man was putting thought in your head in
my head and everybody's head because
when you sit down to watch something
your brain is open you want to go away
that is the exchange between the screen
and the audience
and the what they have been implanting
in american minds we're the nerve center
and our stuff goes to the world so other
people get a watered down version of our
[ __ ] and they certainly have their
own [ __ ] but we're ground zero for
the [ __ ] and what i see being done to
people in the us i just came back to the
us for the first time in almost two
years right
no
you don't deserve this
you have to rise up all of you because
it is killing you
it's not okay to live like this it's not
okay to live in terror it's not okay to
be lied to but you're the number one
person in the world with health care lie
100 lie that you are the brave lie
you're the easiest to scare why because
they control they show you nothing of
the outside world other than terrorism
and natural disasters if the
overwhelming majority of americans don't
have passports other people in other
countries make fun of us for that but
it's not fair to do that why would you
go outside when everything they've ever
shown you on the news is terrifying like
at the bbc corrupt of course too but
they'll be like the weather in addis
ababa the weather in jakarta just this
little side segment so any little kid
watching or anybody has a slight
consciousness that there's a bigger
world that we can all go be a part of
without nations without borders that we
can visit it there is nothing like that
in the us and the frequency
is like the sound that they put on your
news here like it's like bullets in your
body and then the tvs are enormous they
dominate so this stuff is like really
systematically being done it is thought
out it is not accidental it is on
purpose the next time we talk i will
tell you how i finagle my way into
langley the cia
air force ii
the war room the pentagon
and kandahar
kabul
and the last note
if you ever go to war again america and
i'm sure you will do not feed them the
food they fed me at bagram before you go
out to die that is not fair i'm going to
leave you on that cliffhanger
but larry elder [ __ ] you newsom suck it
rose mcgowan ladies and gentlemen
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about women's
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our women's issues playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell